welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain unfortunately our presenter
dr. Cara Ramos is ill and won't be able
to join us today but dr. James gnat and
dr. Saskia Hendrix have kindly offered
to present in her place on the same
topic neurotics an essential partner for
neuroscience dr. Nath is the ni NDS
program director in systems and
computational neuroscience and team lead
for the NIH brain integrative and
quantitative approaches dr. Saskia
Hendrix is an MD PhD and a postdoctoral
fellow at the Department of bioethics at
the National Institute of Health
clinical Center my name is dr. Annette
Carson and I will be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's we'd like to
extend our special thanks to the brain
initiative program directors and in
particular dr. James Matt for all their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting your questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen then type your questions
into the drop-down box
our speakers will respond to your
questions following this presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers free continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right corner of the presentation window
involved the process to obtain your
credits now without any further ado
please join me in welcoming our speakers
dr. James back and dr. Saskia Hendrix
thank you row for the introduction and
our best goes out to row I'm sorry to
Cara and her illness I'm sure she will
be well soon and I do think mic my
colleagues ostia and helping to we'll do
our best to present the material that
Cara had prepared for this so we have a
usual disclaimer here but let's get
straight to the outline of the talk
so what we're going to talk about first
is what is neuroethics how is it
different from other kinds of ethics and
how does it apply to what we're talking
about here the brain initiative then
we're going to talk a little bit about
progress in the neural technology that
we're making in our tool and technology
development in the NIH brain initiative
and then we will finish up with a
section on neuro ethics of the brain and
how neuroethics is actually a global
issue so going to the first part of this
then neuroethics I'll let Saskia who is
a real no ethics expert here carry on
so neuroethics is a field that involves
looking at the ethics of neuroscience
and in neuroscience of ethics will
mostly focus on the first of those two
looking at the ethical legal and
societal implications of neuroscience so
I should say that neuroscience is not
totally standalone field we have
significant overlap and draw on
experience scattered in bioethics in
general including research ethics and
clinical ethics so neuroethics
as a tool of the advancements of
neuroscience neuroscience questions
research raises ethical questions beyond
typical research risks or compliance
issues the most fundamental aspects of
ourselves such as personality and
temperament can be changed rapidly due
to brain injury and in some cases when
interventions premiere your topics in
bioethics such as privacy safety
fairness and informed consent can take
all new complexities given the
unprecedented precision of nooner
technologies and tools and the brain's
centrality to human identity questions
that are important to address include
for example what are the long-term
responsibilities of researchers and
funders to people who receive implanted
neural devices will improved
understanding of brain circuitry allow
for a prediction of risk for future
brain disorders and
zillions against injury Hammond is in
turn affect healthcare insurance and
healthcare policy and how much new
neurotechnologies disrupts fundamental
notions of free will and agency and what
broader implications might be for legal
policies or commercial rounds North
assistance can work with neuroscientists
to address these and other questions
that arise in association with
neuroscience research your ancestors
horizon and the system dissipating and
navigating ethical concerns
this new ethics can serve as a useful
tool that scientists can harness to
assail change neuroscience research
we're going to progress in neuro
technology and the NIH brain initiative
okay so I'll just review a little bit
about a overall overview of the brain
initiative the vision for the NIH raised
brain initiative and as actually we
talked in the earlier session this
morning what we do is guided by a
document of the brain 2025 report
setting out the goals for us to see
circuits in action to understand complex
behaviors such as perception and
cognition emotion and how the brain
circuits dysfunction can cause brain
diseases and disorders the idea being
that if we can make adjustments at the
circuit level in the brain we can make
this the basis of our diagnostics and
the normalization of circuit function is
is one of our goals one of the the
fundamental things about the brain
initiative and our guidance was the
first half of the brain initiative
should focus largely on technology and
device development as well as
development in other areas such as the
north ethics areas and then the idea is
to trance transform into more
investigative neuroscience questions and
their own ethics questions using the
tools or addressing the neural ethics
issues of the tool
that were developed in the first half of
the brain initiative and on this slide
you can see there a journal of
neuroscience issue that includes
actually a summary article on the goal
and the visions and the progress to date
on what we've been doing in the brain
initiative and we would encourage you to
have a look at that so brain funds tools
development to improve health and so I
had sort of just said this this is
especially our early efforts are to
develop tools and on this slide you can
see several of the human disorders and
conditions that will directly be
addressed by some of the early work
that's being done brain initiative and
the examples here are our epilepsy
stroke patients blindness traumatic
brain injury and the use of deep brain
stimulation for Parkinson's disease and
of the neuro psychiatric condition it's
like obsessive-compulsive disorder so
these are all examples of therapeutic
impacts that we expect the brain
initiative to have and all these have
neuroethics is that need to be addressed
in parallel neural technology leading
the way for neural science so the
projected budget for the brain
initiative through actually through 2026
now is over four billion dollars of
expenditures projected for the total
lifetime brain initiative so we expect
the brain initiative to have large and
lasting impacts and fill of neural
science and we hope as well in royalties
there are many other brain projects
around the world is not just the NIH
brain initiative there are other
actually US agencies that are involved
in the brain initiative and as you can
see here there are also international
partners in Union Korea Japan China
Australia and Canada to name a few so I
think the next thing we will do is get
more deeply into some of the neural
ethics issues and I'll let Saskia
address those
so emerging bio technologies have a key
role in driving progress in biomedical
research it's important to unpack the
ethical implications of the science
specifically pertaining to the
development and integration of those
technologies into scientific and
clinical practice this helps to ensure
that science moves forward in a way that
holds the highest ethical standards
so ethics has been a focus from the
start of the brain initiative onwards
President Obama at the time charged the
Presidential Commission for the study of
bioethical issues cigarette neurotics
they've had multiple meetings and issued
a two-part report the responsiveness
fields and one of their main
recommendations was to integrate
neuroethics
from the beginning in any neuroscience
research program now the neural ethics
strategy for the NIH brain initiative
emphasizes proactive ongoing assessment
of the nura ethical implications of the
development and application of claim
under tools and technologies in order to
pursue discharging we work on various
axis we have a neurotic working group
which I'll call emerging brain in a
minute we have published document
occults nor at these guiding principles
we host dr. Cole workshop from emerging
ethical challenges we also have a team
of program directors of the different
NIH teams that discuss the ethical
challenges that come up in their
research and lastly we fund
neuroethics research itself so the NIH
brain neuroethics working group is
fortunate to have members from all over
the US who are experts in their
respective fields and they meet several
times a year to discuss the ethical
challenges that arise from NIH brain
research and provide recommendations for
the nhb initiative on how to navigate
those challenges one of the main
documents that this group has produced
is the neurotics guiding principles
which are meant as
and tools for researchers in the field
of neuroscience to perform the research
in a most ethical way the guiding
principles include one making safety
paramount to anticipate special issues
related to capacity autonomy and
enhancing treaty protecting privacy and
confidentiality of neural data of course
it has to be balanced against the
benefits of hearing data for predicting
and planning possible malign uses here
in science tools an earth the Gandhis
using caution removing neuroscience
tools and technologies into from medical
to non-medical uses identifying and
addressing specific concerns of the
public about the brain as well as
encouraging public education and
dialogue finally to behave justly and
share the benefits of neuroscience
research and the resulting technologies
I recommend ending in all to read the
paper which provides more details on
these guiding principles so we've also
hosted various workshops on topical and
key challenges a couple of the recent
examples were workshop in October of
seventeen on at the quarries issues in
research with invasive and non-invasive
no devices in humans a workshop in March
2018 on research which human neural
tissue such as organoids
and the neural ethics guiding principles
along with the working group meetings
and workshops
are efforts to establish a shared vision
for the ethical conduct of human
neuroscience research and also to
collect and disseminate and associated
back best practices so as I mentioned we
also funding opportunities for note at
this research these were our grantees
these funding opportunities year
and these were different is financially
interesting 18 I won't mention that as
Jim already alluded to importance your
assets work it's being done not just
here but all over the globe
for example the concrete foundation is
working on no ethics issues there was a
club owner a sub 2017 based on which
there was a paper published main
neuroethics questions to guide ethical
research in the international great
initiatives as well as a special issue
in neuroethics in the journal neuron
which was published earlier this year
with various perspectives from different
countries on the neuroethics challenges
of today
the bottom line is this is a
transformative time for the development
of novel neuro technologies the brain
initiative is a catalyst aimed at
revolutionizing our ability to record
amount lake brain function for charity
interventions but what are the
implications of these powerful new tools
and neurotechnologies for health and
beyond now is the time to proactively
consider implications for science policy
new and self-understanding and society
they are sure to visit website which we
also discussed neuroethics edges thank
you
ro I think you need to unmute yourself
thank you absolutely correct thank you
so much see now I have to think so thank
you for so thank you both dr. Sasuke
annex and dr. James knack for that very
informative presentation we will now
begin the live Q&A portion of this
presentation as a reminder please submit
your questions for our speakers by
clicking on the ask a question box on
the far left of your screen we will
address as many questions as we have
time for we do have a question here for
you it's for both of you it's whether
the models desired in brain initiative
research and circuit networks can
intercept those models to solve ethical
or biased reasoning in verifying
cognitive research results or frameworks
Wow so if I undertake them the question
is will we be or can you be funding
research that would actually be work
with the brain activities and the glynn
mechanisms that would be involved in
assessing neuroethics so it's like the
brain studying itself and and the answer
to that is actually in questions that
come in to the brain initiative funding
announcements are investigator-initiated
so to the extent that someone would
propose studies that would do that it
would go through a peer review and if it
did well in peer review yes we could
fund research exactly like that what
does it look like for people to get
involved in these neuro ethics but we
have these awarded projects that have
defined procedures and projects some of
them are doing surveys and looking at
probing information from the community
about ethics how would an individual get
involved with this is a little more
well question I'm not sure we I mean
certainly you can make applications you
could join a team for example by
contacting people who are involved in
neurological issues in your university
or in your sphere of contacts and and
make a collective group application
actually to one of the brain initiative
neuroethics proposals so that would be
one way to become involved but we would
certainly yeah I would suggest that
informations arise on the part of
investigators in brain research one of
the mandates of the neuroethics working
group is to is to respond to consults at
coming consultation they have a
consultation role so renewal and
expression arises you can contact in our
ethics division and we'll pass it on
either to the working group or try to
help you with it to the extent that we
can and we also hope to link researchers
that are interested in working together
within your ethicist through no
ethicists so that's one of the one of
the ways in which we try to help
students out that those two groups
cannot find each other and you know
neuroethics is actually larger ginger
than just the NIH brain initiative so
certainly we would be encouraging to
people to get involved at many levels at
a level we hope that the brain
initiative opens up new avenues for
people to become involved in their
ethics issues and experimental research
so we have another question for you and
also one of our attendees would like us
to reintroduce you again we are here
with dr. James Knapp and dr. Saskia
Hendricks and the question for you both
is are there any guiding principles that
a psychiatrist could use from NIH to
determine competency of a person or is
the decision as for versus competency
still a subjective
the psychiatrist specifically as regards
end of life and physician-assisted death
so I just my part of that answer would
be the our goals are is to inform the
research community give avenues for
understanding more about some of the new
ethical and neuropsychiatric issues in
the clinic it's not the brain initiative
mandate nor our goal to to define what
medical practice should look like we
hope that to create an environment where
a consensus of the medical community
involved in this or sort of activities
and procedures would be able to answer a
question like that so we're not trying
to be dictated on their own on issues
that are really medical decisions in
neuropsychiatry
and to that that for those types of
resources I would refer to sort of
general clinical ethics literature in
which there are definitely established
understandings of what should be tested
during capacity assessments and want the
ethical and legal definitions of
capacity in jail then I would just
comment to this attendee that later on
in this neurotics tract we do have dr.
Francis Chen will be discussing
neuroscience and the law so do come back
and join us then all right so we really
have to move along now I want to thank
you both again for your kind offer to
come and fill in for dr. Ramos and to
answer questions and to inform us about
ethics and the brain initiative coming
up next we have dr. Saskia Hendricks
will continue this discussion about
their ethics and present on ethical
issues in research with neural devices
with humans see you there